you laid out an argument and a framework
to see bitcoin continue to rise in value
could reach you know hundreds of
trillions of dollars or over 100
trillion dollars in value as it
demonetized these other store of value
uh that would lead to a bitcoin price
measured in millions of dollars per
individual bitcoin and i think a lot of
people kind of said wow that's a pretty
uh interesting thesis it's a pretty
bullish thesis and they were drawn to it
what is your kind of analysis of the
progress along that thesis from 2018 to
today so about four years you know three
and a half years after uh you kind of
originally laid that out do you feel
like we're still moving along uh kind of
that same thesis and uh generally
believe the same thing if the odds of it
happening in my head were like 30 back
then they are like 50 now so i would say
it's even higher now every time bitcoin
grows in market cap market cap is
effectively symbolizing the amount of
attention the amount of eyeballs that
are looking at this thing uh the fact
that we
went from 5 000 to 69 000 back to 20 000
right now
in the last three years
has only strengthened the bullet points
that i was bringing up three years ago
and the fact that there are so many more
participants now uh the infrastructure
is even more mature the amount of
institutions is is even bigger uh the
amount of sort of famous famous
celebrities and financiers and other uh
sort of individuals that are
participating and supporting the
ecosystem is even greater now
um
essentially
the chances of everything i was talking
about in 2018 have only increased since
then simple as that in my opinion all
the bullet points still stand
and um the
eventual market cap measured in today's
dollars being over 100 trillion is
completely realistic and when you see
that 100 trillion number it's a big
number what is the expectation timeline
wise you said the probability of it
happening has increased do you still
keep kind of a multi-decade
view from a timing standpoint or has
that been pulled forward at all uh given
what we've seen transpire over the last
three years
i think to to manage the expectations i
think somewhere between
10 to 20 years is is a realistic
possibility could take a little bit
longer could even happen faster but
something to the tune of 15 to 20 years
i think is definitely possible we need
to realize that this is like a long-term
gain and
uh 400 year-old currency paradigms don't
collapse overnight so of course it's
going to take time
but
the fact that there's internet right now
and the fact that these like these
various technologies are decentralized
is gonna make it faster than it would
have otherwise happened and when you
look over the last three years are there
any negative surprises in your opinion
uh kind of the development of bitcoin or
or the adoption of bitcoin is there
anything that's happened that you're
like you know i didn't expect that to
happen or maybe it is a a negative view
of uh of the progress to date
so bitcoin likes when central bank
prints money and it doesn't like when
they contract the money supply now this
the following is going to sound a little
bit simplistic but it does seem that
bitcoin is
even more sensitive to contractions than
what than how sensitive it is to
expansions now of course there's other
variables that play like the stock
markets sort of collapsing as well and
the tech like the tech industry also
kind of experiencing some downturns
but that's kind of one thing to think
about the other thing to think about is
uh bitcoin has become
highly correlated with other sort of
risk assets in people's portfolios
but ultimately i think it was a bit of
an inevitability as
bitcoin kind of matured into a trillion
dollar asset right now i think we are
still in this middle ground where we are
going to mimic
uh sort of
a leveraged technology stock still uh
for the next several years
but ultimately i still think that
bitcoin is
first and foremost correlated with
kind of the global central central bank
monetary aggregates and two to be more
specific so if that continues to expand
which over the medium to long term i
believe it will
um bitcoin price will continue going
higher uh in my opinion nevertheless hey
you did you like this video great make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time